at least one politician Europe is
fearlessly raising an alarm about the
kind of society European elites want to
create one that is rejected unanimously
almost by European citizens in a speech
yesterday kicking off his party's bid
for re-election Hungarian Prime Minister
Viktor Orban warned that politicians in
Brussels Berlin and Paris are going to
destroy Western civilization with their
enthusiasm for mass migration left
unchecked he said Europe could end up
with a Muslim majority well a Condon's
Christian culture would be blotted out
war bond is not crazy actually on a math
level here Hungary's population is below
10 million its birthrate is not high it
wouldn't take a huge wave of immigration
for Muslim nations to overrun and
eventually obliterate a culture that has
existed for thousands of years in
America that's considered a small point
who cares but if you've been there for a
millennium maybe you do care polls show
that more or less most Europeans agree
with that last year majorities in
Germany France Italy Belgium and several
other countries said they wanted a total
freeze on immigration from Muslim
countries naturally though EU leaders
denounced Orban as authoritarian
hilarious considering the source their
motto effectively is do what we tell you
or you hate democracy how's that for a
William